みんなここにいるし、これは日本の財政のビデオなので、このビデオでは、日本のお金について話し、貯蓄を管理する方法など、お金をどのように投資しようとしているのかについて話します。 今日は1時間くらいの時間がありすぎるので、すぐに試してみましょう。これは、聴衆の大多数が 私が約10年前にいたのと同じような立場で、私が意味するのは、より多くのお金を節約したいが、配当や控除などの多くの投資条件にあまり精通していない人です。 途中で説明するので、すでに投資について多くのことを知っているか、私よりも投資についてもっと知っている人にはお詫びします。それでは、最初にやりたいことの1つです。 最初からのストレスは、そのAmerです 米国内国歳入庁のIRSのおかげで、アメリカ人は日本の他のほとんどすべての外国人とは異なっており、基本的にアメリカ人として日本の投資システムや日本の銀行システムに投資したりお金を節約したりすることは困難です。 これについては後で少し詳しく説明しますが、アメリカ人の場合は、相互ファンドやアメリカ企業の株式でさえあるファンドのように、日本人に投資しないことが最善の選択肢であることをできるだけ早く認識してください。 しかし、彼らは日本企業によって管理されている株式のグループなので、あなたがアメリカ人であり、アメリカ人ではなく日本企業を通じてそれをしているので、あなたがそれをして株式市場でたくさんのお金を稼ぐなら アメリカの証券会社や投資会社のような会社や個人の場合は、はるかに高い税金が課せられるので、最初からそれを知っておいてください。最初のことの1つであり、これはかなりのことです。 ここにいる人なら誰でも明らかですが、日本はほとんどが現金ベースの社会なので、これが意味することはかなり明白ですが、毎日行われる取引のほとんどはカードではなく現金で使用され、これは変化していますが、比較のために 私が知る限り、先進国の最初の世界の残りの部分では、米国と比較して、人々は米国よりも多くの現金をここで使用しています。私は絶対に必要なだけの現金を使用しようとしています。 なぜなら、日常の取引に現金を使うと、クレジットカードのようなもので現金を取り戻すことができず、Amazonカードやアヒルのカード、またはポイントベースのクレジットのようなものを持っている場合はポイントを獲得できないからです。 あなたが持っているかもしれないカードとカード日本はキャッシュフェイス社会ですが、あなたが持っているお金を最大限に活用しようとしているなら、あなたが持っている現金の量を絶対に必要なものだけに制限して試してみてください
ポイントを獲得できる、またはキャッシュバックを獲得できることがわかっているカードで他のすべてを支払うので、それが私がやろうとしていることです。それから、私が実際に簡単に触れたい別のことです。これは、私がこれについて本当に知らなかったためです。 おそらく数年前までは、兄はシリコンバレーで働いていて、投資に熱心で、頭が良くて、本当に数字が上手で、正反対です。 クリエイティブのようで、私は数字があまり得意ではありませんが、何かが起こったので、彼が来て私を訪ねてきました。 銀行口座に貯めたお金があったのか、PayPalアカウントの一部が好きだったのか、よくわかりませんでした。彼は私に腹を立てたようでした。彼はあなたのようでした。 あなたが投資に関与するのが早ければ早いので、これを投資し始めなければなりません g後でそれを活用できるほど、投資に早く着手できるようになるので、投資がうまくいくので、まだ大学にいる場合でも、大学を卒業しようとしているかどうかにかかわらず、
10ドルでも100ドルでも、1ドルでも、ポイントが何であれ、すでに機能しているので、できるだけ早く投資を開始したいだけです。投資が早ければ早いほど、両方のお金が不足するからです。 長期的には投資投資投資投資それはこのビデオの一番のメッセージですが、これは前のビデオで犯した一種の間違いだったので、もう1つ明確にしておきたいことがあります。 私は州からお金を受け取ります。それは私のパトレオンアカウントからのものか、銀行振込のようなものか、それとも何であれ、私はPayPalハブペイという印象を受けていたので、常にPayPalを通じてそれを試みていると言いました。 パルは最高のレートを持っていました、そしてこれは真実ではありませんPayPalは転送に関してはまったく最高ではないので、転送ワイズと呼ばれるこのアプリがあり、ブラウザでも使用でき、PayPalよりもはるかに良いレートを提供します 代わりに転送ワイズを使用していた場合、PayPalアカウントから日本の銀行口座にパトレオンの収入を転送していたときに毎月数百ドルを節約できた可能性があります。 私は自分のお金をパトレオン口座に入れ、月末にそれをPayPal口座に送金し、それを自分の口座または投資仲介会社に引き込むか、日本の銀行に引き込むことができました。 アカウントは基本的にPayPalから取得できますが、日本に送信する場合はレートが非常に低く、最初にPayPalに送信するのではなく転送を使用してストリップと呼ばれるサービスを使用する場合 eそしてそれはあなたがそのパトレオン口座にあるお金のほぼ100パーセントを特定の銀行口座に直接送ることを可能にするので、私はそれをすべて米国の私の口座に送り、そして必要なときだけ私はお金を送金します 州のその口座から私の仲介口座から私の日本の銀行口座に送金を使用して申し訳ありませんので、私が強調したいもう一つのことは、あなたがアメリカ人である場合、あなたが日本のアメリカ人である場合、私はできるだけ少なくするのが最善だと信じています 日本でできるだけ多くのお金を持って、すみません、タイミングで本当に迅速に何かをチェックする必要があります。9分でアメリカのシステムにできるだけ多くのお金を投資してください。少し詳しく説明します。 これ以降の詳細ですが、日本国外から送金する場合は、銀行振込を使用しないでください。PayPalを使用しないでください。コンビニエンスストアのようにローカルATMを使用しないでください。 あなたのようなアメリカの銀行口座からお金を引き出すのは、彼らがあなたに30ドルのように請求するので、あなたが長期的にたくさんのお金を節約するという最良の選択肢である日本の銀行口座を持っているなら、300ドルのように転送を使うのが賢明です それはあなたが投資できるお金なので、間違いなく日本に送金するための最良の方法です。もう1つ話したいのは、今どのようにお金を投資するかということです。すみません、水を一口飲むつもりです。 アメリカ人が利用できる最新の金融アプリやものが好きになると、いわばループから外れてしまったので、これについてはあまり知りませんでした。それは私が生きてきたからです。 州外では約10年間ですが、現在、OneTouchソリューションのようなアプリがたくさんあります。ウェルスフロントもその1つだと思います。改善もそのひとつだと思います。基本的に、単一のアカウントを作成してから、 多分わからない 月に100ドル、あるいは月に1000ドル、あるいはそれがそのアカウントに含まれる可能性のあるものなら何でも、それはロボット投資家のようなもので、あなたのために投資を引き受けます。これは実際には本当に良いオプションだと思います。 多くの人が、日本のアメリカ人はこれらを使用できません。これらのサービスは、再びアメリカにいるアメリカ人である人々だけが利用できるので、これを行う必要はありません。これは、私が以前に話したものとは関係ありません。 ああ、実際にはそうかもしれませんが、ポイントは、米国に住んでいる場合はウェルスフロントや改善などのアプリを使用できないため、できることは非常に多くの関心が高いもののいくつかを使用することです 現在、さまざまな銀行のオンライン普通預金口座を作成できます。このため、サイトnerd wallet comにアクセスすると、さまざまなサイトのリストが表示され、そのサイトの銀行でオンラインで普通預金口座を作成できます。 たとえあなたが いくつかの銀行がある州の外では、伝統的な銀行や日本の銀行のようなものと比較して、その銀行の内部であなたが持っている節約に対して本当に高い金利を提供するでしょう。 申し訳ありませんが、ここで少し熱くなっているのですが、日本の通常の貯蓄口座のように、ああポイントゼロゼロ1パーセントまたはポイントゼロ1パーセントのようなものなので、基本的には何もありませんが、オンラインで高金利を使用しています 貯蓄口座も同様で、その金利の貯蓄は2パーセント以上です。今は2ポイント1または2ポイント2パーセントのようだと思います。名前を付けるつもりはありませんが、 私が以前に使用した銀行は、私がこぼしたくない種類の個人情報を知っているので、皆さんが見るようにそれをブリーチする必要があるでしょうが、あなたができるオンラインの高金利銀行はたくさんあります 海外のアメリカ人として、これは本当に良い選択肢の1つです。たとえば、毎月パトレオンアカウントでお金を稼ぐときは、PayPalアカウントに送金するのではなく、興味がないのです。 私はすぐにそれを私の高金利のオンライン貯蓄口座に送ります。そこで私は毎日少しの興味を持ってその口座の中にお金がありますそして必要なときだけ私は支払いをしているときにその口座から私の地元の日本の口座にお金を送ります 家賃やユーティリティなど、食料品などを知っている場合でも、ポイントを獲得できるので、クレジットカードのようにドケットカードを使ってみます。実際に食料品で支払います。 コンビニエンスストアに行くたびに、ポイントを獲得できるクレジットカードを使うので、支払いを受けるたびに、ほとんどすべてのお金が私の高金利のオンライン貯蓄に使われます。
ntとそれはもう少しもう少し興味を蓄積しますそしてそれから再び必要なときだけ私はそのお金を日本に送り返し、私がより多くのポイントを獲得できるように常にクレジットカードを使ってそのお金を使うようにします これが最良の選択肢であると信じていますが、高金利のオンライン普通預金口座は、おそらく2％のように、おそらく2.25％のように、おそらく2ポイントのように3％のように戻ってきているので、これまでのところしか行きません。 普通預金口座の場合、通常はわずかな手数料でいつでもお金を引き出すことができるので、1ドルのように、基本的に必要なだけお金を引き出すことができます。 世界では、あなたがすでに接続している他の銀行のために、または普通預金口座ではなくACODを使用して、お金がそこに閉じ込められているので、このお金で大丈夫と言うことができます私は任意の数を言います$3,000私はそれを選びます 行くつもりはない このお金に3年間触れることができますが、銀行がそれを完全に管理するので私は触れないので、私はより高い金利を得るでしょう。 もう1つのオプションは、もう少し保守的ですが、通常は預金口座の証明書も提供するため、これらのサービスを提供する銀行を通じて高金利のオンライン普通預金口座を使用している人にはかなり良いと思います。両方が表示されます。 それらの中で、あなたのお金の大部分を高金利のオンライン普通預金口座に入れて、それからあなたが預金口座の証明書でそのお金に触れることができないのであなたが本当に必要としないだけかもしれない少しだけ持っているのがおそらく最善です 金利は高くなりますが、触れることはできないので、もう少しリスクが高いので、次のことは実際のことなので、株式投資のように、IIはわかりません。 ええと、アメリカ人は1つのオプションではなく、1つのオプションしかありませんが、私が知る限り、アメリカ人が州外で使用できる大手証券会社の株式投資会社は1つだけであり、その会社はInteractive Brokersであるため、サインアップできません。 ヴァンガードアカウント、チャールズチャールズシュワブアカウント、メリルリンチアカウントなど、日本に住んでいるアメリカ人なら、世界の他の場所に住んでいるなら、これらのアカウントを作成できることは知っていますが、 現在日本に住んでいるアメリカ人にはサービスを提供していませんが、Interactive Brokersという会社はそうです。私は彼らと仲介口座を持っています。IIもかなりの金額を株式市場に直接投資しているので、私のお金の一部は行きます。 貯蓄口座に入れて、それから私がパトレオンとYouTubeから毎月少しのお金を受け取ります、そして私が少しでもすることのようなさまざまな小さなことはどんな手段でも取るに足らない金額ではありません nsしかし、毎月その貯蓄口座や預金証明書に入れられないお金の一部は、Interactive Brokersアカウントに移動して株式市場に投資し、ETFにのみ投資します。ETFは上場投資信託なので、親切です。 株式のバスケットのように、すぐに多様化できるので、リンゴの株式やアマゾンの株式のように購入するのではなく、魅力的であるか、テスラの株式のように、非常に魅力的です。 テスラが欠陥のあるバッテリーのクラッシュなどのリコールのようなものをいつ持っているのかわからないので、それは非常に危険です。 彼らのバッテリーとそのようなもので練習するので、そのようなことが起こるときはいつでもあなたはもっと多くのリスクを伴うでしょうが、もしあなたがおそらく千のdifを持っているETFを持っているなら 猛烈な株とその中のあなたはちょうどそのETFの100株のように買うことができます、そしてあなたはあなたが投資ではるかに多様化されているのであなたははるかに多くなります 大きな市場のクラッシュではありませんが、それでもあなたは私が言おうとしていることであるはるかに良い位置にいるでしょう、それで私はETFにのみ投資します、そしてこれは私が入らない最良のオプションだと思います 少し詳細ですが、IIは少しの配当を行います。配当とは、会社が利益を上げる場合は常に、上場企業であり、利益を上げる会社であるため、すべての会社がこれを行うわけではありませんが、場合によっては 企業は利益を上げたときにその利益の少しを株主に還元するので、Appleが作ったように、特定の年に明らかに1,000億ドルの任意の数字がわからない場合は、多分彼らは私たちがそのようなものを持っていたと言うでしょう 素晴らしい年 株式を所有しているすべての人に、各四半期の初めまたは各四半期の終わりに1ドルを受け取る、各株式AppleのAppleを提供するので、私はその配当を次のように与えました。 会社がその利益または収益を投資家に返済するときであり、あなたがその株の株を保持するのではなく、その株が時間の経過とともに価値が上がることを期待して、あなたはどちらかを戻すことができる直接現金を得るでしょう 同じ株に投資するか、配当を支払わない株に投資することができますが、価値は時間とともに徐々に増加しているので、かなりの量のETFを行います私はかなりの量の配当を行いますが、それはすべてインタラクティブブローカーを介して行われます 私が日本に住むアメリカ人として作ることができる本質的に唯一の証券口座の株式取引口座であり、もう一度繰り返したいのは、あなたがアメリカ人であり、ETFではないETFを購入した場合、 アメリカの証券会社が運用しているので、アメリカの株式しか入っていないETFをもう一度購入したが、まったく同じ株式であっても、そのETFは日本企業が管理している場合、同等のアメリカのETFが請求されます。
IRSからより多くのお金を払わなければならないのは、アメリカ人が海外市場に投資するときにIRSがそれを好むので、それを売るか、そのETFから配当を受け取ることによって利益を上げるとき、私はアメリカ政府にもっと多くのお金を払わなければなりません。 あなたはアメリカ人であり、アメリカの会社を通じて投資したいのですが、それはあなたが国際的に投資できないという意味ではありません。あなたがアメリカ人であり、チャールズ・シュワブやヴァンガードなどのような会社を経由する場合 彼らは国際株のみで構成されるETFを持っているかもしれませんが、そのETFがその会社によって管理されている場合は、ニューヨーク証券取引所で取引されていることを知っています。 その中のトックは国際的ですあなたは大丈夫だと私は信じていますあなたがアメリカ人ならもう少し注意して少し読んでください私は主にアメリカの株式市場に投資しようとしますそして私は再びインタラクティブブローカーを通ります それが基本的に私が利用できる唯一のオプションです。現在日本でも利用できるロボ投資サービスのようなものがたくさんあるので、テオもその1つです。これもまた、このウェルスウェルスウェルスフロントまたは改善のようなものです。または、そのようなさまざまなサービスを知っています。 クラブは、ピアツーピアの投資サービスのようなものですが、あなたが再びアメリカ人である場合、州からのロボソリューションを使用することはできません。また、日本で提供されているロボソリューションも使用できません。 あなたはあなたの配偶者に年間最大1万ドルを与えることができます日本政府はそれを容認しますそしてあなたは彼らにそれをロボサービスに投資させることができますがロボは さまざまな日本の企業が提供しているのは、通常、米国の企業よりもはるかに高いレートです。また、株式市場に参入してETFに投資するよりも、はるかに優れていると思います。 オプションですが、私が知る限り、日本に住んでいるアメリカ人の場合は基本的にこれが唯一の実行可能なオプションです。アメリカ人で日本に住んでいる場合は、インタラクティブなブローカーアカウントとオンラインの高金利貯蓄アカウントを作成するのがおそらく最善です。 海外に住むアメリカ人にそれを提供し、それから非常に多様なETFで株式市場に参入するいくつかの銀行がありますそうですそれは私が投資に関して私がしていることであり、私は私のために投資しているだけです 今は2、3年はわかりませんが、もっと早く始めていたらよかったのにと思いました。
t JEPあなたがジェット機を始めているなら、私は好きです、そしてあなたがコンプに住んでいるならあなたは月に500ドルのように、あるいは月に1000ドルのようにさえ節約することができます 多くのお金とあなたは年間1万2000ドルを節約していますそしてそれは私がアメリカの株式市場で平均的な年のためにかなり合理的であると私が思う5パーセントを知りませんそれはあなたよりはるかに多くのお金になるでしょう 来年は後で投資できるので、クミンの累積利息で基本的にあなたが持っているお金が多ければ多いほど、いつでもそれにもっと興味を持ってもらうことができます。 あなたが持っているすべての1ドルは小さな労働者のようなものだと考える必要があると言いましたお金はあなたが商品や商品と交換できるものだけではありません 知ってるね いわばタティックであり、投資を通じて、高金利のオンライン貯蓄、CO D、または株式市場のさまざまなオプションのいずれであっても、できるだけ早く投資を開始してください。個人のローカルアカウントは大丈夫です。 多くの人が税金について質問するので、アメリカ人としてもう一度申し訳ありませんが、日本に住むアメリカ人としての私自身の個人的な観点からしか話せないので、基本的に私は知っています アメリカ人でない場合は、さまざまな日本の証券会社のように日本政府が提供するサービスを利用する場合に、より柔軟に対応できるはずです。 それはオプションですが、アメリカ人として日本に海外に住んでいるアメリカ人なら税金に戻ることはできないので、これはちょっとクールです。あまり多くの人がこれについて知らなかったのです。 これについても長い間ですが、あなたが活動から得たお金を支払う必要はありません。私が今していることは、私がオンラインでビデオを作成し、毎月のお金の大部分をパトレオンから得ていることです。 これはアメリカの会社なので、私が日本で働いているのに、そのお金はアメリカの会社から来ているのに、私は日本で仕事をしているので、IRSアメリカ内国歳入庁はそのお金に課税しません。 約10万ドルまで信じているので、そのお金はアメリカの会社ではなくアメリカの会社から発生しているが、アメリカの会社から来ているとしても、アメリカ政府はそのお金に課税しないので、あなたがアメリカ人なら 日本に住んでいて、年収が10万ドル未満の場合、基本的には、日本政府または米国政府のいずれかに税金を支払うだけで済み、99％の状況になります。 地方の日本政府だけでお金を払っているので、IIは今はかなりうまくいっていますが、IIはそうではなく、私が日本に引っ越して以来、アメリカ政府に税金を支払ったことはありません。 多くの人がよく知っていると言っていますが、YouTubeのように、アメリカの会社を通じて生み出されているお金をもう一度知っていますか。それをIRSに報告しますか、それとも日本で報告し、 日本は少なくとも私のアメリカ人と日本の税務会計士が私に言っているので、年間10万ドルの基準額を超えない限り、実際に二重課税されることはありません。その基準額を超えている場合は、とにかく会計士を雇う必要があります。 おそらく長期的にはあなたにとってより儲かるでしょうが、すみません、私はチェコの時間を本当に早く取るつもりですええ、基本的に私が試しているように二重課税について心配する必要はありません ここで言うと、私は毎年日本で税金を申告するときにすべての地方税を処理する地方税の会計士と、グリーンバックグリーンバック税サービスまたはグリーンバック税などのサービスを使用しています。 まるでアメリカの会社が特別に作成したようなものです。アメリカ人駐在員に精通しているアカウントのグループなので、アメリカ国外に住んでいるアメリカ人は、日本国外に住んでいるアメリカ人であれば、収入を報告する必要があります。 一定の基準額を下回っている限り、税金を再度支払う必要はないので、年間約400ドルかかると思います。おそらく、年間500ドルだったので、すべてを送信します。すべての領収書を送信します。 または、私の費用の内訳を知っていて、パトレオンからの私のお金やGoogleからのお金のように、すべての収入だけでなく、キーボードに新しいオフィスチェアを持っている場合などのすべての費用も知っています。 私はそれをすべて差し引いて彼らに送ってから報告してくれるので、あなたが知っているように書き出す必要はありません。 日本は基本的にあなたがアメリカ人ならこれを知っていますが、毎年あなたの税金を報告することは世界で最も苛立たしくて迷惑なことですそしてそれは私があなたに対処しなければならない最後のことですそして私が支払う必要があるなら 私に代わって400ドルまたは500ドルの誰かが私に代わってそれをするので、私は喜んでそうします。そうすることで、私は実際に代わりにこのようなことをすることができます。 それから私はアルタに住んでいる地元の日本の会計士がいて、私が日本政府に報告するときに同じ収入をすべて報告するために一緒に働いているので、毎年彼を使って約1年半になります 私がファイルしようとしたので推測 自営業の日本でのアメリカ人としての私の税金は、世界最大の悪夢のようでした。地元の税務署の人々は皆とても親切で、彼らはとても助けになりたいと思っていますが、正直言って何もありません。 彼らのほとんどは、少し衝撃的なPayPalのことを聞いたことがなかったので、YouTube、パトレオン、PayPalのようなものに本当に慣れているので、私は入って、基本的に言っていました これは私が稼いだ金額であり、これらは私の費用であり、基本的にはこれが何であるかはわかりませんが、これらの数字があれば何かがうまくいくはずなので、基本的に私は 3時間か4時間くらい彼らと話をしなければなりません、そしてそれはまさにこの大きな巨大な頭痛でした、そして私は私が最良の取引のようになっているかどうか、そして最良の取引ではないかどうか本当に心配しました、しかしあなたはあなたが バリについて知らない多くの場合自営業 税金から控除できるので、年末に税金を申告すると控除額はどうなりますか。結婚しただけで結婚している場合は、配偶者控除のようになります。 もしあなたが日本政府に借りがあるのなら、あなたが年末に稼いだ金額が、あなたがコンピュータのような仕事に使うためにあなたが支払ったものを取り出した後の5万ドルであるかどうかはわかりません。 このマイクやこのカメラ、あるいはそれが何であれ、それは6万ドルを意味するかもしれませんが、あなたはすべての費用を取り除いて、あなたは5万ドルまで下がっていますあなたは日本で結婚するためだけにその配偶者控除のような別の控除を使うことができます 約3,000ドルだと思うと、その50,000ドルから再度控除できます。その後47,000ドルになります。これが日本政府が課税できる金額なので、控除額が多いほど、明らかに優れています。b なぜなら、それはあなたが一日の終わりに日本の税制に支払うお金が少なくて、私自身の個人的な哲学や私自身の個人的な信念やそのようなものにあまり入りたくないので私は知りません しかし、私は日本政府と米国政府一般の政府はほとんどのことを行うのは非常に非効率的だと強く信じているので、私は自分のお金を営利目的の企業に直接投資しようとすることを強く信じています。 結局のところ、基本的にはすべての人にとってですが、ええ、それは哲学の観点からはそれぞれ独自のものであり、あなたが物事の社会的側面にもっと興味があるなら、それはまったく問題ありませんが、私はできるだけ少ない税金を払うように努力しています 毎年の終わりに可能な限り、そして明らかに私は常に私のさまざまな会計士を通して完全に合法で安全な方法でそれを行いますが、あなたが知らないかもしれない多くの控除があることを知っています 地元の会計士に相談してください地元の日本の会計士は、いくつかのことを知っているだけで、そうでない場合よりもはるかに多くのお金を節約できる可能性があります。自営業の場合は、基本的に2つのカテゴリの人々がいます。 日本での税額申告と自営業者の中には2つのタイプがあり、申請する必要があります。ブルータイプと呼ばれるものか、申請しなければならないタイプだったのではないかと思います。 このタイプの場合、そのタイプであるための控除を受ける前の年なので、最初の年のように、私は日本のパトレオン収入に対する税金を報告しました。私はその申請をしていませんでした。 千ドル程度の税金かそこらで、一年前に青いフォームを申請するだけで千ドルを節約できたと知っていたら、明らかにそうしていたでしょう。
lf-employedで、今年は間違いなく自分の収入を報告する必要があります。間違いなく地元の会計士に相談するか、地元の税務署に行って、青いフォームまたは私が思うかもしれないものを申請したいと言います。 青いフォームや緑のフォームを話さずにコークスのように見えることはありません。そのフォームを介して税金を報告するだけで、1日の終わりに5,000ラウンドのようだったと思います。 あなたが借りている合計金額から6,000ドルを差し引くと、1日の終わりに支払う必要のある金額が約1,000ドル少なくなるので、会計士を雇うのは常に良いことです。 その中で、お金を節約する方法に関して彼らがあなたと共有できるさまざまな知識があるので、私のアメリカの収入と日本の収入の両方を報告する会計士がいるので、それは良い戦略だと思います。 多くの人が退職金のようなものや社会的社会保障のような日本人のようなものなどについて尋ねたので、これはあなたが日本で自営業であるかどうかにかかわらず、地方税の会計士を持つことが良い理由のもう一つの良い例です または、あなたが会社で働いているのか、非営利で働いているのか、それとも日本の年金制度に支払う必要があるのかを見てみましょう。これは、Cokely意味のゲームと呼ばれ、一律の料金だと思います。 あなたがいくら払ってもそれにお金を払うすべての人のためにそして私はそれが月に約150ドルだったと思うので今私は私が自分自身と私の妻の両方に支払わなければならないことを支払いますそしてあなたはそれに支払いますそしてあなたは知っています 政府はそのお金のすべてを管理しているのですが、理論的には、私が60歳になると、そのお金を取り戻します。
40年30年で 今から私の年金の支払いは私の社会保障になりますが、日本の人口は劇的に減少していることを誰もが知っているように、これはつまり、日本の人々は本当に本当に長い間生きているので、日本ではますます多くの人々がいます 毎年、高齢者の数は指数関数的にではなくX増加していますが、生まれる人の数よりもはるかに速く成長しているため、高齢者は本質的に若い人を上回っています。これは、その会社のお金が 毎年日本政府を通じて引退する人々に行きますこれらの若者たちが私たちの苦痛である新卒者であり、彼らはますます多くのお金を払わなければなりませんそして多くの人々が日本に再び住んでいるからです 引退後、彼らは75歳や80歳のように死んでいないので、おそらく100歳のように亡くなっているので、40年分の価値があります。 年金のお金とそれは現在働いている人々に大きなストレスをかけるので、ますます多くの人々が支払うことはありませんますます多くの人々が日本で働いている現在日本人で働いている人々は少し払っています もう少しそのような人々は、成長している高齢者の人口統計セグメントがそのお金を稼ぎ続けることができます、そして日本の若者はあまり投票しないので、ほとんどの高齢者は政治に投票します 年配の人口なので、私が彼らに利益をもたらすものへの投票を言うことができる限り、通常、年配の人口は、多くの人々が政治に関与していないため、お金は通常、彼らにほとんど知られていないことを意味します もう一度言うことができる限り、これは明らかにすべての逸話ですが、人口動態の問題のために、基本的に現在、日本の年金制度には大きなストレスがあります。 今起こっているので、あなたは日本の年金制度にお金を払わなければなりませんが、私は日本の年金制度をあまり信用していません。 地元の日本人の税理士が私に紹介してくれたのは、この追加のタイプの退職基金があり、あなたが自営業である場合に適格な人々であり、あなたは私が15万ドル未満のように私が知らないようだったと思います 会社にいる人が5人未満の場合、または基本的には小規模企業や個人労働者向けの年金制度である場合は、1年程度です。 それには月に600ドルかかります。これはスライディングシステムのようなものなので、月額700ドルまで支払うことができます。今はうまくいっていれば、そのお金を変更することができます。」
mパッティング 月額600ドルで600ドルですが、来年はあまりうまくいっていませんが、月額100ドル程度まで下げることができますが、そのシステムにお金を入れている理由は、退職金でできるからです。 控除としてが正しい言葉であるかどうかわからないので、そのお金を帳消しにしますが、もう一度大丈夫なら、これは基本に戻ったようなものですが、毎月千ドルを稼いだら、報告する必要があります それは日本政府に私が言ったのですが、私はこれだけのお金を稼いだと彼らは言うでしょうあなたは費用がなくても控除がないのでこれの25％または20％を取ります しかし、そのお金の一部を100ドルのような退職基金に入れると、それは退職基金なので、それを帳消しにすることができます。そうすれば、日本政府に再度報告するお金は1,000ドルにはならず、9ドルになります。 百ドルだから彼らは大丈夫だと言うのであなたは千ドルを稼いでいるが100ドルは行く sを退職基金に入れると、月に900ドルしか課税できなくなります。これは、私たちが課税できる金額であり、900ドルを受け取るつもりはないということではありませんが、その金額にしか課税できないので、 再び900ドルの10％20％のようにかかるので、退職基金を作成する利点は、基本的に、非常に長い間触れることができないお金を使用できることですが、それを支払うのではありません。 あなたが承認しない何かのためにそれを使用しているかもしれないか、あなたが知っている無駄かもしれないか、彼らがそれを効果的に使用しているかもしれない政府にそれはあなたがあなたのために節約することができるお金であり、あなたがあなたが 引退するので、コークリーの苦痛に加えて、公的政府年金制度に加入することを意味します社会保障制度私も毎月この小規模年金基金に支払いますので、月に4、600時間のようでした たくさんの費用がかかる 月と多くの異なる方法で行われる多くのトランザクションですが、私はいくつかの異なる収入源を持っているので、YouTubeがあるので、ページがあります。 アマゾンやそのようなもので、それから私はヤフーでいくつかのことをするので、私は小さな取引のようなものをたくさん得て、すべてが今起こっている私の頭のてっぺんから100％確実ですが、私はそのお金のいくらかをその小さなものに行きます 通常の年金基金に加えて規模の年金基金も同様にそれを行うことの利点は、あなたが政府に支払う必要がないより多くのお金であるため、すぐにアクセスすることはできませんが、 日本の年金制度全体が今ストレスを感じているので、何度も引退したときにもらえるお金は、60歳や65歳のときに年金がもらえるとは思えません。 古い私は薄い k実は、私たちが70歳のときのようになります。なぜなら、日本のみんなの平均寿命は年々長くなっているからです。IIは、私と私の家族をサポートするために日本政府に自信がありません。 コルカを介してインクを意味するので、私が支払う年金があります私が支払う小規模な年金があります私はあなたにその両方からジャンクションを知ってもらいますそしてそれらの両方に加えて私は私の別々の投資もすべて持っています 繰り返しますが、お金を節約できる方法と投資できる方法はたくさんありますが、お金を節約できる可能性のある方法が常にあり、さらに多くのお金を持っているので、すべてのオプションを知っておくのは常に良いことです より多くのお金を活用するより多くのお金を持っているより多くのお金を投資の基本的なルールのようなお金を持っているだけで得ることができますが、私は逸脱しているので、他に何が欲しかったのか見てみましょう oカバーそれは、私がエコーしたり、ニサやそのようなものが好きなことについて私に尋ねた少数の人々のほとんどすべてだと思いますが、私が読んだことから、そして私の地元の日本の税務会計士が持っていることから私が話したことから これらについて私に言ったのは、アメリカ人がこの種の資金を使うのは危険だということです。なぜなら、これらの日本人の退職者に対する税制上の優遇措置は基本的に日本の退職金であり、月に700ドルかそれ以上の投資ができるからです。 毎年日本政府に支払うであろう日本人に支払う金額からそれを差し引くことができますが、それはあなたがその700ドルを投資してお金を稼ぐ場合のように追加の税制上の利益があるということです 私がエコーしたり、ニサをさまざまなストーキングインデックスに入れたり、高配当の株式オプティオに投資した場合のように、それからお金を稼ぐときは何でもかまいません。
nニサまたはIデコを介して、まったく課税されない可能性があります。これは、これらのアカウントを持つことの利点の1つは、一定のしきい値まで免税されるため、配当からお金を稼いだり、売却したりしても、課税されないことです。 あなたがその特定の退職基金で保有している株式は、どのようにそれを行うのかはわかりませんが、とにかくある程度固定されていると思うので、投資することには多くの利点があります。 ニサを通してですが、あなたがアメリカ人の場合は非常に複雑なので、今は間違いを犯したくないので、当面はそれらに触れないことを選択しました。 あなたがアメリカ人でないなら、確かに私デコとニサについてたくさんの研究をしてください。なぜなら、私が知る限り、これらは両方とも長期の退職基金にとって非常に良い選択肢であり、あなたは再び退職基金を持ちたいからです。 日本の年金制度は それをカットするつもりはありません、そして2030年でそれは悪夢のような大きな時間になるでしょうそれで間違いなくそれらを調べてくださいそれは基本的に私がさまざまなものの約50分間話している単純な実行の単純な要約です お金を使ってやっていることをいくつか質問に答えてみようと思いますので、申し訳ありませんが、多くの人に答えることがわかっていたので、事前に経験を積んでみたいと思いました。 質問多くの質問が寄せられたので、今度は質問に取り掛かりましょう。私はSUNYだった大学に通う学生です。日本の大学にも通っています。卒業後もそこで働きたいのですが、全額を費やすつもりはありません。 後でアメリカに帰るような生活をしているのですが、どうやって片足を持って、日本の両方のアメリカに足を踏み入れようとしているのでしょうか。
t
oクレジットを構築
するクレジットカードや日常生活などを使ってローンを支払った後も、
特に雇用された後は、貢献し続けたいと思い
ますが、日本に住んで円を稼ぎ、
銀行の下で過ごします
簡単に行き来する方法はあり
ますか？転送の賢明な使用転送の賢明な
ええと私は海外
での
支出やPayPalまたは
他のオンラインタイプのサービスの使用のために無料で国際カードを取得することを考えてい
ました 私の間違いでした。私の
円を米国に交換することをお詫びします。
会計士は私たちと一緒に日本に戻って過ごします。私
が指摘したいことの1つは、
日本でお金を稼いでいて、日本に住んでいるなら、それでいいということです。
そして、そのお金は再び
日本で生成され、日本の
どこかからあなたの
銀行口座に送金
されます。それは、日本政府によって課税されることになるでしょう。
もしあなたが
日本に住んでいて、そのお金が
アメリカで生み出されて
いて、それをアメリカから日本に送っているなら、あなたは
そのお金を報告するだけで
いいのです。 見てみましょう
外国人が分類されるようなランクのカテゴリーがあり
、日本で税金を報告するようになると
、日本に留学し
ていてオンラインのようにやっている場合のように、私は信じています
-米国でお金を稼いでい
て、そのお金が日本に送られることのない時間の仕事
あなたは私が知る限りその期間に日本の税金を支払う必要はありません
が、あなたが次のランクアップであなたが
あなたと言うなら 日本に住んで
2、3年くらいはわかりませんが
、アメリカで稼いでいるお金を送っ
て、それを日本に送ったら、その金額だけが課税されます。
あなたが日本に送ったお金、
そしてその後の次のランクアップ
はあなたが蜂のようです n
日本に5年間
住んでいて、日本に永住するつもりなら、この要件を満たせば、過去10
年間に少なくとも5年間日本に住んでいることが規定されていると思い
ます。
そうすれば
、日本国内か
海外かを問わず、日本
に送金するかどうかに関係なく、あなたが稼ぐ金額
は課税され
ます。つまり、私が稼ぐお金の大部分はそれです。
私のさまざまな
オンライン活動を通じて毎月日本に送金されることは決してない
ので
、パトレオンとグーグルとヤフーの両方で月に任意の数の4000ドルを稼ぐと
したら、私が関わっているすべてのものは、
仮説的に言えば
、そのすべてのお金 毎月
400ドルの10％
を日本に送金しただけでも、
食料品などの支払いや
、非常に安いアパートに住んでいたら家賃を払うために、米国で発生しました。
本当に安いアパートのようなもの
はまだ100ドル
課税されます
私は日本に送った400ドルではなく、
日本に住んでいたので私が作った合計4000ドルに課税されていたでしょう
少なくとも過去5
年間日本に住んでいるので
、これもまた
日本政府
が設定した税制であり、私がすべてを完璧に言ったかどうかはわかりません
が、あなたが行くと私は
思います それは落ち着いた日本のガイドですそして
あなたは基本的に彼らの税金のセクション
に行きます彼らはあなたが日本に住むであろう各カテゴリーをレイアウトしますあなたが
それを米国に送る必要があるときはいつ
でもあなたが円を稼いで彼らの銀行の下で支出します ええ、
私がヨークの特定の状況について言いたかったのは
、あなたがYouTubeのような
ことをするかどうかにかかわらず、米国からお金を生み出すパートタイムの仕事をして
いるなら、それは良いことだということです。 日本では
t 一時的に
、アメリカ人
から日本に送金しない場合、
アメリカ人の口座に残しておくと、
一時的に日本に行くだけなので、日本の税金を払う必要はありません。 ですから、日本に来るかどうかに関係なく、州から
の私の収入のすべてを報告した後はそれを行うことはできませんが、
あなたは一時的にここにいるだけではないので、あなたはそうし
ません その5
年または3年のしきい値または5つのしきい値を満たすと
、米国でそのすべてのお金を保持でき
、日本の税金を支払う必要はありませんが、
Japanguide.comにアクセスし
て税のページにアクセスしてください。
あなたがどのブラケットに該当するかを正確に調べて
ください。
私が会社に勝ち取った退職金制度について本当に知りたいの
ですが、将来には十分ではないように感じます。
とISA
と私はaddressinのかなり良い仕事をしたと思います
gアメリカ人の場合
、IDEエコーまたはNisaアカウントを設定することはお勧めし
ません。たとえ、
それを作成できる日本の配偶者と結婚していて、
それらを介して投資できる場合
でも、これも最大
金額であるためです。 配偶者に毎年贈ることができ
、日本は1
万ドルなので、一部の人にとって
は良いことです
が、10
ドル以上の投資を計画している場合、年間10,000ドル以上を退職基金に投資することを計画している場合
、私はそれです
あなたの配偶者を通しては大丈夫かもしれませんが、
IIは私がデコと
ニサについて本当に強い推薦をするのに十分なことを
知りませんが、私はおそらくあなたの
国籍を知らないと思いますが、私も
そうは思いません
長期滞在するかどうかは別として
、アメリカ人でない場合はデコを調べ
、アメリカ人の場合はニサを調べます。
インタラクティブブローカーを利用します。日本の年金制度をペイントする必要があります。
関係なく、最後に私がすること
はyです
あなたが話している会社
がコカの意味であるかどうかはわかりませんが、
それが日本政府の退職金
制度であるかどうかのように、私が最初にすること
はあなたの特定のことについてもっと理解することです
あなたが会社に確認するために支払っ
ている退職
基金は、あなたの退職基金が何であるかを正確に把握
してい
ます。
それについて
は先ほど話しましたが、私は過去10
年間で5年以上日本に住んでいるので
、毎月パトレオンから稼ぐ
お金はすべて、その月のお金が日本に来なくても報告します
今月は日本
に送金する必要がないほど前月
に日本にかなりの金額を送金したことを知っていても
、さまざまな収入源のすべてから得たすべてのお金を報告する必要があり
ます。
毎月 日本政府なので
、パトレオンでお金を稼ぎ、それを
高利の口座と
証券会社の口座の両方に送金しますが、
毎月その設定された金額をもう一度
稼ぐとき、私が持っているお金である任意の数をもう一度4000ドルとしましょう
日本の地方税務署に報告するので、高利のオンライン貯蓄口座に預け入れられ
た金額を確認したらすぐにその
スクリーンショットを撮り
、日本の地方税務署に
送金します。 これは
私が毎月稼いだ金額だと言い
ます。その時点から、私
が行った税金に一定の金額を支払う必要があると仮定して、
その税額を差し引い
て、残りを投資します。
そのお金を日本に返送する必要
があるときはいつでもそこに少し残しておき
ますので、パトレオンに関するあなたの質問に答えて
くれれば
、アメリカの税金を払う必要はありませ
ん。  n日本に住んでいるアメリカ人は、
日本に報告している限り
、アメリカ
政府にも報告し
なければなりませんが、年間100ドルの基準額を下回っている限り、税金を支払う必要があります。
ですから、私が本当に迅速に対処したいもう1つのこと
は、
あなたが日本に住んでいて、複数の収入
源があり、自営業ではない
場合、私は非常に長い間
APUで働いていて、パトレオンをしていました。
年間2000ドルまでの
追加収入だと思うので、パトレオンをした最初の年のように
、年間2000ドル未満しか稼げなかっ
たので、APUの給与に日本の地方税を課していましたが、そうではありませんでした。
私がパトレオンから作っ
た年間2000ドル未満の2000ドルで何かを払っています
が、翌年私は
あなたが副収入で年間2000ドル以上を稼ぐとすぐに2000ドル以上を
稼ぎました
あなたが報告を始めなければならない会社
もう一度報告を開始する必要があるので
、これはあなたが私のためにどのブラケットを使用しているかによって異なります。
私は5歳だったので
、すべてを再び日本に送っていなかったので、報告しなければなりませんでした。
日本に2年しか滞在していない場合は、年プラスブラケット
そのお金が日本に届かない場合は、その収入を報告する必要はないかもしれませ
ん。
日本に住んでいる期間
や特定の経済
状況によっては、常に収入を報告する必要
がありますが
、その収入に対して常に税金を支払う必要はない場合があるため
、次の質問に該当します。適用する予定の次の質問を見てみましょう
。 アメリカからのジェットプログラムに
、移動をできるだけ簡単にするために何をすべきか
など、私がすべき特定の銀行がありますか？
ジェットの場合はおそらく非常に
状況が良いので、それが意味するのは
その何人かの人々
真っ只中の阿中に
行くと、地元の教育委員会から住宅代金が支払われ、
基本的にすべての
ジェット機の全員が作っているのと同じ月額3,000ドルを稼ぐことができますが、そうする必要はありません。
住宅を支払うと彼らは日本の非常に安い地域に住んでい
ますが、スペクトルの反対側では、彼らの住宅を支払っていないジェットプログラムで東京
の真ん中のように配置された誰かがいる可能性があり
ます
すぐ
に穴に千ドルのようにあるので、ジェットは非常に
状況が良いですが、
知っておくと良いことは
、大学を卒業してすぐに月に3,000ドルは、ほとんどすべての
日本の新卒者が作るよりも多い
ということです。
あなたがやや質素
な生活をしているということは、私が
今ジェットプログラムで住んでいるオレイサに住んでいて、
かなり質素な生活を送っていたように、月に少なくとも500ドル節約できるはずです。 月額300ドルの
アパート
で、ジェットプログラムに参加していたときは月に約1,000ドル節約できました。
辞めるまで
に、ジェットプログラムの3年間で約25,000ドルの30,000ドルを節約でき
ました。
私がそこにいた最初の年の真新しいオートバイ
私は非常に小さいものになりますが
、それほど高価ではありませんが、
それでもそれほど
質素ではなく、
3,000ドルはほとんどの日本人よりも多いのでかなりの金額を節約できます
人々が作っている
ので価値があるのは良いことですが、私が
実際にお勧めするのは
バックストン楽天を作成することです。LOXtang
は日本のアマゾンのようなものです。彼らは日本のアマゾンをたくさん提供
しているので、彼らと一緒にアカウントを作成することをお勧めします
.comアカウント
カードも提供していると
思いますが、クレジットカード
を使って日本で何かを買うたび
に、とにかくたくさんのコンビニに行くので、クレジットカードを作ってくれます。
日本に住んでいると
コンビニエンスストアに行くので、コンビニエンスストアに行くときは必ず
ポイントやキャッシュバックなどを貯めたクレジットカードを
使って頑張ってください。 ギンケル
と言って、毎月の電気代など、
できるだけ多くの費用をかけてみてください。車で支払うと、いつでもポイントを獲得できるので、いつでもポイントを獲得できる
ので、お
勧めします。 見てからゲームロック、それで銀行
それは良いもの
ですが、おそらく
あなたが知っていることは何でも、地元の教育委員会は
おそらくあなたに地元の大きな銀行口座で口座を開設させるでしょう、
それで
私が最初にここに引っ越したときのように私は作成しました
銀行の口座と
私はまだ彼らの口座を持っています
私は銀行に耐えられません彼らは基本的
に彼らについてあまり多くの悪いことを言うことはないと思い
ますが
私は私のHortaにできるだけ少ないお金を入れます
ba 毎月のnk口座
は、そのお金でまったく利益が得られないと思う
だけでなく、銀行に行くたびに、私が
銀行の大ファンではないことを常に人々が知っているからです。
私は大丈夫だと
言いたいのですが
、日本に誰かのための安全な普通預金口座があります
が、それでも私たちが
家を買うか、今後5年間より大きな投資をするかどうかはわかり
ません私は
あなたが何であるか完全にはわかりません 「日本で安全な
普通預金口座をよく言いたいのですが、
これは先ほど言ったことに戻り
ますが、日本の
銀行は普通預金口座の面であまり良い金利を提供していない
ので、もう一度思います 最善の選択肢
は、常に
地元の日本の銀行
口座にできるだけ少ないお金を持ち
、多くの異なる会社
が現在提供している高額のオンライン普通預金
口座にできるだけ多くのお金を持っていることだと思います。 関心の高いオンライン
普通預金口座と彼らは 海外に住んで
いるアメリカ人としてもサインアップできるはずのオプションのリスト
、そして
株式市場にいなくて
も、あなたがアメリカ人かどうかわからないので、私ができるかどうかわから
ない Interactive Brokersをお勧めする
かどうかはわかりませんが、少なくとも、
高金利のオンライン貯蓄口座は
、圧倒的多数の人々にとって良い選択肢であり、
必要な場合にのみ転送を使用して
、4番目に補うことができます。
月に3000ドル
ジェットプログラムに参加している
としましょう。月に3000ドルを稼ぐことができ、
さまざまな費用で月に1,000ドルから1,500ドル
を費やす必要があるとしましょう。
再びあなたの自動車保険と
そのようなもののようにそして多分あなた
は買い物のために追加の$500を持ちたいと思うかもしれ
ません私はあなたがあなたのNetflixアカウントのように助けを求めているのか分かりません
ds
月に数回ガールフレンドがいる可能
性があります他の重要な$500は
、社会の一員として楽しみたいさまざまな方法を楽しんでいることを知ってい
ますが
、その$3,000アカウントの約1,000ドルを節約できれば
あなたがそれを節約し
ている限り、あなたが毎月最初の$ 1,500を持っている限り、あなたが
その追加の
1000ドルをその高利の
オンライン普通預金口座に
入れるならばあなたの住宅とユーティリティとそれらすべてのものに支払う方法を設定します
転送
ワイズ
を使用する場合はある程度の金額を支払う
必要があるため、転送ワイズを複数回使用する場合は、転送ワイズを使用する場合は、それを元に戻す必要はありません。
あなたがそれを非常に頻繁に使用している場合、transferwiseはpaypalと比較して非常に安いですが
、それは
あなたのお金を高金利のオンライン普通預金口座に入れるという目的を無効にします
そもそも、
高額で稼ぐよりも送金手数料に多くのお金
を費やしている可能性があり、それから
最初に興味を持っている
ので、常に
あなたが決して入れない金額だけを入れるようにし
てください
あなたの高金利のオンライン
普通預金口座に日本に送り返す必要があるのはおそらく
あなたにとって良い選択肢だと思いますそしておそらく
ほとんどの人にとっては大丈夫
だと思います私の娘の一人が
目覚めたかも
しれないと思います 戻ってきたので、
娘の1人が目を覚まし
たので、すぐに彼女に食べ物をあげる必要がありますが、
ここでビデオを終了します。
まだかなりの数の
質問に答えたいと思います
が、 今日は時間がないので
、やってみるのは、
これらのビデオ
を作るのはそれほど難しくないので、実際に編集する必要がないので、これからやって
みます。
このビデオへのフォローアップフォローアップ
ビデオそして多分一週間か二週間のように
私
があなたたちのために答えることができる追加の質問が
あります。下にコメントを残してください。
次のビデオでそれらに答えようとします。私自身の信念に関して少し個人的になりすぎ
た場合は、このビデオでお詫びします。
経済学や政府の役割
など、
誰もが自分の信念を受け入れる権利があり、他の人に
押し付けようとはしませ
んが、ええと
、少しでもお詫びします。
あまりにもそれに夢中ですが、彼女は少し
不機嫌になっているので、私は行かなければなりません、そして私は
あなたたちとすぐにまた話します